You made it!!!
Welcome to the FAILGATE!
I don't get it. We have to go watch the teams
that beat us?
Oh God no. We drink a lot and try to
forget the postseason
Whoa hold up, there's a POSTseason?
I don't get it. Who are all these excited people?
Jared, these are fans!
Oh I've heard about that!
Do you have fans?
Yeah, I did
Hey Bills fans, look, I hate tables too!
NATHAN, NO. YOU DO NOT HAVE
THE COORDINATION
Bills Mafiaaa!
OW! My eye!
AHHHH!
Tickets, tickets. Just thousands of tickets
that we no longer need
Franchise quarterback. Got your franchise
quarterback here! Anyone looking for a
franchise quarterback? Only $30 million dollars
Hey, yeah, um (cough) I'm interested
Coach, come on, we gotta go beat the Pats!
Not a catch
Ohh?
Yo who wants to shotgun?
Oh hell yeah!
(snap of can)
C'mon hurry up in there!
I got beat by Nick f--king Foles